okay
for those joining this live stream we
are doing a language completeness and
consistency
meeting with a variety of topics first
on our list
naming of generated data destination
option
okay so this go ahead yeah so this is
something we discussed
earlier this month and we came up with
the name generated data destination
and i guess after nobody likes it you
basically
okay fine all right
so let's understand where we know we're
going to use it
okay so uh
well maybe carlo can give a better
answer to that than i am
but uh right in functions like spin
speech synthesize right where or
yeah video there is another one
okay so this is the thing where
basically
functions that always generate a backing
file correct
or usually do right so one of the
you know and like in video generator it
always has to create one because we just
can't store that
in memory but um with the audio
functions you might be able to say
none and store it in me yeah well in
some world of the future when memories
get bigger
you know and everybody has a petabyte of
memory on their computer might be a
different story
right but at the moment they're not
going to human i mean like audio there
was a time when you couldn't store audio
right
now you can store audio just fine um
so and us humans unless we get an
upgrade
the the you know the amount of data in a
video
isn't going to go above some value
um
okay so
go ahead yeah so so carlo and i did some
brainstorming earlier and and that's the
first
one under the uh and in the last group
there's generated resource location i
don't like the word resource because
we've got
we're using resource to represent you
know our resource system and so on
okay but
what do we call
i mean is it always a file the thing
that we're generating
well uh it could be a cloud object or a
local object yeah well we need to i mean
this is crazy look at this this does not
show a single use of persistent value
a persistent location rather
yeah it does under scope or what do you
mean it doesn't show a single use
this is just creating the position this
is just referring to the persistence
location
it doesn't say how the persistence
location is used
anywhere
you see what i'm saying
right so that's what i want to see here
because this is defining this is a
symbolic representation
this is a different thing this is saying
persistence location
as a rapper right that's different from
what you're doing
isn't it yes okay so that's wrong to
begin with right so
what is the analogous thing for
persistent
value persistent value has a way of
saying
okay i see it's a second argument a
persistent value
but doesn't persistent value have an
option doesn't don't some of these other
things have
okay persistent value
okay so what has an option
do you understand what i'm asking right
i'm not sure
anything has an option and switches
maybe some in this sense it's maybe a
little bit new
um right because sort of
right cloud object right you just give
it the
right so this thing one could imagine
that it would have a
as a setting persistence location of
blah
and that's a symbolic representation of
rather than saying explicitly you know
this file name that's a symbolic
representation you see what i'm saying
right but it certainly couldn't support
arbitrary persistence locations
no but it could support some of them
right so the same ones we uh
allow as naked strings yes we could also
theoretically
support okay so so this could imagine
could be imagined
to be um
so persistence location is a rapper
yes so what this needs to represent
okay is it the case that these functions
are always going to have
a a destination or are they going to
look up from this location
how does that work do you understand my
question
and not entirely no okay all right so
audio capture
for example is mostly writing to this
location correct
correct yes okay does anything
read from this location as well
no not unless you explicitly get right
if you give it
the audio file that was you created
using audio
as its main lunch but not as its main
lunch no
no but no no the you give it as the main
lunch
the location not as an optional you know
piece so to speak correct
okay okay so this is really
when the function is going to persist
itself
persist things i mean this is
really analogous to the persistent value
business
because persistent value
is um
well versus i mean the persistence
system is for persisting wolfram
language expressions
and this is for the computer you know
persisting out of core
data like wave files offsets
yeah all right okay right so so if you
don't like resource then
maybe generated asset location right
because it's
going to tell you where do you store the
wav file that's backing this audio
object
anybody still uh i'm still here do you
hear me
yeah you cut off for a second okay i
like the word asset
so are do you like generated asset
location
it's not terrible shoddy carlo what do
you think
i'd be okay with that i i think the main
thing that i was
not convinced was the destination uh
suffix
so so you're saying
so generated asset
right okay so this might say
generated asset location goes to
persistence location
in addition to all the other modes that
we could have like
explicitly specifying something sure
um why don't you like the word
destination
the only use we have thus far of
destination is in geo-destination
so it seemed
so so will we have a dollar generated
asset location
correct
and it's a directory of some kind
it could be an explicit
specified by persistence locations
right so so the default will be
automatic which means you know
choose a location that's sensible for
that function
like you know will from document
directory audio or will from document
directory video
but you know you could make it
yes if you wanted to overwrite your file
every single time you could give it a
file name
or you could give it a directory and
okay so let me ask a suggestion
this dollar will from documents thing
okay
which by the way should surely be
dollarable from documents directory or
something
i think that's just yes okay
all right okay so i'm going to claim
that that should be a persistence
location in the persistent system as
well
i what does the persistent system write
into persistent okay persistence
locations
local objects it writes local objects
what is a local object when it's just
seen on a disk
is it it's it's a directory metadata
it's yeah it's actually a directory with
with you know uh a wolfram language file
describing properties of the
and then any added resources so why is
it that we're not using local objects
as the uh storage for these videos and
things
there's a that's one of the parts you
could just say
generated asset location goes to local
object whatever
that would work no but what do you mean
local object whatever you mean
persistence location local right
but yeah that that means create an
unnamed local object
in the default the local object store
location yeah okay
whereas okay but so for some reason
you don't want to put things on the
local object store i don't really
understand why you don't want to
because the local objects
uh are in a hidden portion of the file
system and you may want to
actually see these files that you've
generated
okay fine so then what i strongly
suggest
is that we have the exact same idea for
local objects with the exact same
wrapping so that they can be managed in
the exact same way
but we simply have another persistence
location
which is this visible file system
location okay
so in other words um
[Music]
which i think is really quite a good
idea so in other words
this persistence location okay could
that's this will be local and there will
be a local visible or something
local documents maybe is another
persistence location which means exactly
your directory that you've defined
see what i'm saying
i'm not sure i i i mean
i i am not an expert on on the
persistence framework but i'm it's not
clear to me that that makes sense
because my
my conceptual understanding of the
persist of the persistent system is a
way to persist
wolf from language expressions not
arbitrary
well i i understand that but i'm
suggesting
that we can generalize it a bit
okay because we want to keep the same
framework because we're going to have a
lot of the same issues about cleaning
things up
about managing it etc etc etc so why not
use the same framework because we've
already solved those problems
and this took like a year to build i i
am not convinced that
well those problems have been have been
solved i mean
if they haven't been solved they need to
be solved and they need to be solved
once rather than
once for this system once within your
building and so on
so i think what what we should do
and we should have had the person from
the persistence framework
i.e roman here probably too late to
reach him today
i suggest that we have a thing called
local documents here
that is another persistence location am
i making sense
well i underst i vaguely understand what
you're suggesting
it's not clear to me that it makes sense
okay well i think it makes sense
so i'm i'm pretty certain it makes sense
um
[Music]
and not all frame documents call it
local documents
i think it should be called local
documents unless it's a centralized
thing
for it's for your for that user's
documents directory right
no it's it's a subdirectory of the of
dollar user documents directly no no i
understand i understand i understand but
it's
on a per user basis right it's not
central
to the installation it's a per-user
basis correct yes
yes okay so that the the consistent
thing i think is to call it local
documents
um now here
okay
so there is one one point that i
brought up that i think is still a bit
unclear um
he said persistent values
are not particularly
relevant for files they are more
relevant for a generic wolfram language
expression
while that is true local objects
can be used to store files and
persistent location can be used to
figure out where the local object stores
the file so i've grouped together
persistent location and local object and
kind of
persistent value created as a separate
entity and not particularly
relevant to this no i agree persistent
value is not relevant
yes i agree with you um
so this persistent space is also not
relevant because it's part of
the persistent value part of it but what
is relevant
and persistence path is also not so
relevant although it might become
relevant for these things later on
um
yeah this is all irrelevant this
persistent object stuff is irrelevant
but the persistence location is highly
relevant
um i see so you're just suggesting
that persistent location of uh
of uh well for example
of local documents would be a symbolic
representation of
dollar worth from documents directory
for whatever the current user so
rather than burning in your own will
from documents directory
you have a symbolic representation of
that value
that's what's equivalent to saying
object yes i i i agree that that's
a sensible thing yeah and this can be
achieved right now if you use the second
argument to local object
you could set that to whatever directory
as far as right see there are other
things here
itai which are also quite useful like
local shared i can imagine being useful
well if you're if if you have
if you're rude or you have changed the
the permissions on
you or you're running or or you're
running on some little raspberry pi or
something which doesn't have a user
system particularly
i i don't know i mean it you know this
is it's something where we don't have to
rebuild the structure
right well local share is supported it's
just not particularly
useful for right because most users
can't write
to dollar base directory i understand
but but it would be useful let's say
you've got a class
and you want everybody in the class to
work on the same video
you don't want everybody's local
directory you know documents directory
to have that video in it
mm-hmm yep so so i mean
okay so let's walk through again how
this would work
so generated asset location
would go to either the raw location
or persistence location of
quotes uh local documents
right yeah or local or local shared
cloud
right but this what your your criticism
of this local here
is that it is in a hidden file yeah i
mean it will still be supported
right there's no reason to not support
it but i'm not sure if you need to
continue supporting that i know you
implemented that in your branch but
maybe we should just continue supporting
generated asset location goes to
persistence location local
to get that not the shortcut sure sure
but the point is that would be it's just
a convenience for the user sure
but yeah i mean i i'm i i think you
shouldn't allow the naked string
because that's fine it's generated asset
location which you do sometimes want to
be
presumably a directory name yeah yeah
right fine
we can we can make that change i mean
generally that's that looks
right so so so last time you you seem to
be settling up we should support these
as naked strings
and then use file to disambiguate but
i'm happy to go in the opposite
direction
that was my preference to begin with i
don't care which one i agree
i like that better too the the naked
string is defaults to a file
that's fine but it's actually defaulting
to a directory not a file right
depends on how it is passed right uh
if it is recognized as directory no i
understand that but but i'm saying
no no but you have defaults it defaults
to a file
stephen if if that if that string
corresponds to an existing directory
then we take it as a directory
otherwise it's it's a file
well with the trailing slash probably
right yeah
yeah if you want to force it to be
interpreted as a directory you
have the trailing slash but in most
cases
right you're going to be storing to
directories that already exist
right so either you'll leave it at the
default and with the auto generated name
right so let me put it this way dollar
generated asset location will typically
be direct location of local
documents
um that will be its default value its
default value will be automatic
all right fine but i mean i think that
automatic is probably persistence
location of local documents
well i guess it could be but
but it has a disadvantage of creating
curve in addition to the actual
asset right um and
achieving pretty much the same effect
right okay i don't know it doesn't
matter to me
yeah all right i think we have a path
here yep
okay location one
one other last thing when we were
brainstorming names we thought about
possibly another option that would refer
to existing assets for any function that
would want to
consume an existing file and i guess if
we call this asset generated asset
location
asset location could be the other option
we don't need it now
but i i think it's good if you think
about that as well now
yeah it's a little unclear to me
what the purpose of this other option is
well i mean i think that the better name
would be persistent
asset location or something and then it
will work for both ways round
and actually i don't think that's such a
bad name because i think for audio
capture if you see that name
it's telling you there's going to be
something generated that is persistent
i actually really like that name so you
say audio capture and then it has an
option persistent asset location
which is often set to persistence
location of something or other
right i guess the question is
so it's still not unclear to me what
this other option
charlie was referencing i think it
refers to
but is there a case where both of these
would be needed
i was trying to find a case where
potentially both would be needed
an editor an editor something that edits
you both have to pick the video up and
you have to put it somewhere
but i think in that case the the
location is going to be the same
you're going to want to pick it up and
put it in the same place probably but
how do you specify which one you want
no but the location is going to be a
directory which particular one you want
i don't know
possibly in some name
i think the editing scenario you're
saying definitely requires two separate
options
unless in a lot of cases now we just use
arguments for
one or the other yeah i mean the reason
i don't like generated asset location
audio capture it's not clear how
generating it is i mean you
are speaking to your computer and you
are generating the sound
and your computer isn't really
generating much at all it's just
transcribing what you said to it
the function is generating enough i know
right
but i mean you could argue that but i
think persistent asset location
is a clear thing to say because it's
telling you
this function is going to leave detritus
behind
right which is a non-trivial fact right
it's not a temporary file
the only argument that i would have i
would be okay with that name the only
argument i
would make is that that doesn't
necessarily confirm to all the
persistent star function just the
persistent
location one
i think it's okay with respect to the
other ones i really think it's okay
i think a persistent value and all that
kind of thing i think it's okay
that's what i would suggest check it
with roman but that's that's my
suggestion
okay all right onward
do not get distracted by cosmological
rest frames and other such
things yes because so basically we
discussed this
in june and then
when we had some follow-up meeting uh
ian and i both watched the video and
realized that
we talked about all these other things
but we never actually discussed the item
okay so let's go back to the item
okay right so there is uh
what is it called echo timing right
and it has a method option
uh to specify which can be
repeated which can be
or something right and so
and so yes do we want to
you know basically at the moment we can
think of two
exactly two places where this will be
used echo timing and
presumably repeated timing could
basically take two values timing i mean
it's kind of crazy right because
it's it's i mean there might be some
other places what about verification
tests doesn't it have a timing option
better it does i would expect it to have
like a time constrained option but not
yes
yeah that is that is okay so that's an
interesting thought
time constraint what is time constraint
is it absolute time
or is it is it cpu time it's usually cpu
time but one could imagine a version of
time constraint that's absolute time
no time constraint is is is absolute
time
is it yes because
right because i mean just do positive 10
with
time constraint go well that's you know
time constraint goes to two
right that it's not using two seconds of
cpu
time to to evaluate pause
i didn't know how that worked is that
right if i say time constrained
well this that this fact actually means
large portions of functionality
particularly in calculus
give different results depending on how
busy your system is
how fast your system is and an idea of
an
operation constrained came up many many
years ago but is apparently
onerous to consider yes
utterly unpronounceable and becomes ever
more unpreventable
you know did you hit the you know how
many operations are really going on in
your cpu
right and and are you counting each
course separately for those things which
can be multi-threaded or
that's right and even much worse than
that i mean it's hopeless
all right so the issue here is
you know given
how you know why what is echo timing's
argument structure right now
one argument
so doesn't it doesn't it also take a
label isn't it one or two argument like
the other
echo thingies
yeah i think so so this one you might
need to prototype build because i
don't think has this been merged to
master or is this in the pr still
i don't remember timing function is in a
pr
echo timing is in twelve two
apparently not defuturized yet though
but i'm pretty sure it also takes a
label just like the other echo
just like echo does
which if we
look for now why don't you have a method
thing why don't we consider this
experimental because i think we're going
to want to change that
okay i think i mean we could also give
it
i think yeah i think this is the only
plausible thing and that means that the
label can't be method arrow blah blah
blah
right you're using up that by by
identifying that as an option right
let's tag this as experimental i think
we should solve this problem i mean for
now let's just use this that's fine
okay i i think it's not a perfectly
clean solution
okay okay process we're looking for
deprecated symbols
okay can i make a comment here i i am so
fed up with seeing in the autocompletes
seeing all these random internal symbols
over and over and over again
why what's happened to our whitelist
blacklist
it's still there are you sure you
haven't uh disabled the blacklist
um and and what sort of what sort of
internal
symbols are you seeing i have no idea no
idea i mean i'm just
if i try saying ec okay i didn't get
that
eb i mean i i have no idea i mean um
i haven't seen it yeah i always have the
opposite problem
that um you know i want i wants to auto
complete to my private symbol and i
can't
because those are blocked
well if you're a system developer yes
they're blocked but the private symbols
are blocked but they shouldn't be
blocked
okay well all right i i'll have to find
this
explicitly okay let's see
right so i mean this is
okay this is this is uh perhaps a missed
title thing but
uh so the question is about will from
language data once
so so the procedure has been that you
know
what's a symbol is marked as obsolete it
is completely removed from wolf from
language data
yes i think that's the right thing i
think you should have an entity class
that that supports them
but the one the zero argument form
should not return them
um but they're not entities
they're they're removed so that for
instance the entity count
does not get artificially inflated by
the fact that we have renamed a symbol
twice or whatever
so the entity will just disappear if we
remove it but why don't we have it
rename then why don't we do this
why don't we have an entity in a
different con in a different
why don't we call it um what are the
entities called
in in the in well from language symbol
is the
okay so when we call it wall from
language obsolete symbol
that's a different entity type move its
entity type
yeah i i like that idea better than
trying to shove everything in
five minutes type would those be
accessible via will from language data
or would you have to use
entity list and no i think you should be
able to get wolf language data zero
arguments should not give them by
default
agreed right but i think you should be
able to get them
somehow i mean if you type in well from
language data of quotes
something obsolete i don't know what's
obsolete um
i can't even think
which one compose yeah compose that's
definitely right okay
okay so what language data of quotes
compose
should give you all the various you know
standard data about it and it should
return
as the entity well from language
obsolete symbol
okay okay yeah that's doable and
and maybe we will from language data of
quotes obsolete gives you all the
obsolete ones if
if you want sure why not
if you really want to you know honor the
dead
right well i mean you see well uh
the i mean the reason this keeps popping
up
is that you know you complain why is
this obsolete
symbol appearing in this example well
because we have no way to search for
obsolete symbols
okay well good great so there's this is
this is what motivated this discussion
even though it's
you know right well i mean you could
complement
everything in system with what's
involved from language data but you
probably don't want to do that
it's definitely cleaner to explicitly
curate one baseline
solution i really like the wolfram
language obsolete symbol entity
okay right so this was just passed to me
as something that's supposed to be
thought about but i have n i i maybe
have a guess for what one of these is
but not what the other is
so okay so i think this is the situation
okay so we have this says i don't know
whether i can do this can i do control
dollar
it doesn't work yet it should have been
the prototype build
i'm pretty sure okay i just okay
there's an open pull request that should
be merged in a few
more days okay so control dollar
oh look at this exciting exciting
okay frack one i'm about to actually use
this for a real project
so cool okay
okay so
now did that just parse and disappear or
is that just the box that will
okay so it's clearly some sort of ui
thing
it's a box yeah it's a box right now but
i i'm surprised there isn't some kind of
check mark that allows me to just sort
of say this is what i
no no this is a box because it isn't
actually oh great
um because it isn't actually that this
was a case where it was happened to be
meaningful in the language
right but often it is not right
okay so
and i don't know exactly how good it is
i'm out of luck um okay
so here are two things this is what i'm
thinking here
okay i don't think this is quite right
this latex render form thing
but the main issue is
if what do i want to do here
so i want to be able to type i mean if i
type
something like this here import string
you know uh frac
one seven
why does that say failed probably
it wants the dollar signs right so what
i'm imagining is late
also right that's not plain tech i don't
know if we make
that distinction i don't think we make
that distinction
yeah okay all right okay so this is what
i'm talking about okay
so what i want is a function okay so
this is all
not what i want okay what i want is a
function that is a very simple wrapper
around these
that simply does what that control
equals thing does
and takes this and returns
a you know a thing that prints as bo you
know that
that that display right that basically
if you do notebook put of percent
whatever that
percent 64 is or 84 i can't quite read
right
so something that looks like the cell
that's generated by this
thing yes except not even the cell i
want it to be an inline
yeah presumably probably an inline cell
in other words in other words what i
want to be able to do i want to be able
to make a table
of okay so here's the example of what i
want to be able to do i want to be able
to make a table
of expressions so let me give you the
full flow
okay um
i mean i'm let me just say tech
rendering that's not the right word
but of of something where it's a string
here blah blah blah blah blah
forget let's say let's say the simplest
case i make a table of 10 of these and
what i want it to do
is just display as a bunch of you know
as a list that has
that looks like you know whatever it is
table
you know whatever it is
okay that looks like that even though in
actuality these are inline cells or
something
right makes sense
so it's in other words it's doing the
same thing that control equals is doing
but it's doing it from a string that i
type in rather than from a
well they're both strings i type it a
string that is perhaps programmatically
generated
rather than just the control equals box
makes sense okay so then the remaining
piece to this picture
is uh um string templates for latex
okay so what do i mean by that um
what i mean by that is uh
i want to be able to put in let's say
i'm making a table
of i don't know the uh
category theory some weird category
theory diagram
that i can represent in latex but i have
a programmatic way of generating you
know
it's the um it's some exact sequence of
you know homotopy something or others of
something or other okay sure
and i've got data and all i want to do
is to put in i want a 3 here a 7 there
or 14 there etc etc etc i want to
essentially splice that into the tech
code
you see what i'm saying so it could be
that string template will just work for
that i'm not sure
okay right yeah i don't see why it
wouldn't
i mean probably it does we just have to
think about it okay
so i'm i'm saying that um
um in which case that's that will be
just fine
in which case then what it would look
like is um
tech rendering of string template of
blah blah blah blah blah
now does tech rendering just sit there
and format does it actually evaluate
away to something
do you that's a good question i don't
think it should evaluate a way
i don't think it should evaluate i think
it should sit there as
a thing that displays
as mm-hmm
i mean what is the right term for that
thing it it displays
it is it it eats tech and it
yeah and so it renders it renders as
right it renders as tech
basically it runs
as boxes right in other words
okay inside it's a pig
tech it's dressed up to look like a
peacock
okay i mean i don't know what the the
stupid terms okay whatever
it's it's got um uh
um i mean we could call it something
very simple like you know
tech fragment of blah but
no it's not obviously wrong
does that give the sense of the display
tech display
that's not quite right what function do
we have so so
so the closest precedent at least to my
mind that we have is
raw boxes right it takes boxes
and it just displays as the rendered
boxes
that's such an obscure name um
yeah it's a deeply obscure name which
probably should be updated
um
what else do we have that is i mean like
you know the things that sing and you
know that display like graph obviously
displays as a graph but has something
else inside
well well i think the problem is that
people don't think of what's the inside
as being distinct from the graph
right um
tech fragment is not obviously bad
[Music]
i mean at least then people would
understand it's a fragment you don't
have to put the dollar signs
blah blah blah blah blah blah
all right let's go for that let's go for
that and that's basically what we want
is just an implementation of whatever it
is that's working in
in control uh dollar should just work
here
okay and and whatever it is that comes
back from control dollar
you could use that here i don't see why
not i mean
that whatever object that is that comes
back it can be put anywhere
it's not um
do we really want we shouldn't say wedge
four we should say wedge
um uh uh wedge doll dollar
okay so i mean if i say um
i don't know enough tech but but you
know
okay beautiful okay so now i say
okay what's full form of percent
wait a minute what's that that got
interpreted
it did didn't it i see yes so that's
interesting
so this is
okay let's ask well this may be a defer
of some
or some something like that this this
so so so so let's try the following
which is
like something like slash left
uh you know and then the left brace
and then x squared
dot you want something you want
something that isn't isn't
understandable
correct okay tell me what to type
uh backslash left
[Music]
and a left brace
and i know x carat two
and backslash right
and the period period like that
yep
okay so i guess it doesn't like it
because it couldn't interpret that
no no it's got to interpret the boxes it
doesn't have to interpret beyond boxes
okay but that that is one oh oh oh you
brace was a bad choice
uh replace the brace with uh paren say
okay because that is definitely valid uh
did you delete the period or is it just
yes restore the period
yeah you need something after the right
to be what to use there period means use
nothing there you go there we go
okay all right so what happens if you do
a table of that guy
okay if i evaluate that guy it gives us
syntax error okay
so it renders his boxes but it doesn't
protect you from
right so this would have to be something
well i guess it could be a cell renderer
it could still interpret as itself
but this would be something slightly
different right so so this is
this here is an entry thing and and this
here is a display thing so this would be
an encrusted display
that has you know boxification and tech
fonts and all that kind of thing
and then what it needs is some way of
taking that encrusted thing
and interpreting it so what will be the
natural way to do that so we need a
function
that just returns the encrusted
stabilized boxes from this
right well i i think that's probably
import with with some elements but i
could
but i'm sure it is implementationally
but that's not what i care about
what i care about is what we want is
something which can readily take this as
a string
and produce this as a stabilized output
i'm sure it's i'm sure it's
implementable well why isn't that just
tech fragment
okay so tech fragment then okay fine so
tech
fragment comes back as a stabilized
bunch of boxes
okay what happens if i want that
stabilized set of boxes
to now if i want to now interpret it
[Music]
no i don't i don't understand at all
right true expression is a good answer
to expression is a very good answer if
we can make that work that's a really
good answer
because it it is it should be stabilized
boxes and so long as we can make two
expressions
eat those we're in good shape
[Music]
by the way is this not fixed still this
was supposed to have been fixed like
a year ago stupid yellow with a stupid
yellow thing
what's wrong with the stupid yellow
thing we have a new design
okay
i don't think that i i have not seen a
new design for that anywhere
it was like a year ago
okay um
well i don't think it's been implemented
it's the short answer
um damn it okay
in any case i need to go to a different
meeting in a moment here
um this question on the live stream
about the mart tech package
in the community which i'm assuming
we're quite aware of
we are aware of it well is there is
there something more specific
than just matec i don't think so
right so basically it's a it's a way to
sort of easily
embed the tech fonts into visualization
functions
oh somebody was just asking me about
this
um and
yes i don't remember yeah i don't
remember the details
but that is sort of its intent uh
to so if you want to produce you know
your perfectly
textiled plot that you can just plump
into your paper
um right okay i get it so it's a
slightly different objective
yes it's interesting okay because this
is using our old tech interpreter that
was written 25 years ago
that actually goes to boxes so okay so i
think the right answer is tech fragment
produces stabilized boxes
to expression takes those boxes and
tries to turn it into an expression
make sense so let's see if we can get
that
that that would be
quite unusual um for for two expression
to have a special
handling of something i don't know
but but it is to expression of boxes
is something that deals with them this
is just all these boxes i don't know
wait so you're so you're telling so
you're saying that tag fragment will
evaluate the way to boxes
yes that's what i'm saying um oh you
would think you would have a print form
that's boxes
because if well if it evaluates a way to
boxes
right it's not going to display no no
you're right actually this is not a bad
idea so so then
what look here's the right answer you're
actually giving a better answer
okay so so what you're what you're
suggesting is
i like your answer better okay okay so
tech fragment here
this displays as the tech fragment boxes
okay whatever it is like that okay then
two boxes of that or two expression of
that
would do what you would think it should
do
yeah that's the one i i'd have to think
some more
why don't you think about that i'm
optimistic about those working
okay really i'm optimistic i think this
is actually very nice that's a good idea
to have that just be a print form
very nice idea right because then then
it's like
this it's a programmatic version of this
nothing really happened it was just a
print form
now i don't exactly know how you seep
through with standard form traditional
form and so on that's a separate issue
probably this is like
i mean it's a little confusing that tech
form
is printing as tech because it's the
opposite direction
yes it's printing as tech just like
traditional form prints as traditional
but this is a tech fragment inserted
yeah that's the right thing this is the
right thing this is good
now if we can get these two to work
we're in great shape
um all right i need to go
all right good stuff we got through our
agenda
okay bye bye